cette vidéo est sponsorisé par cooper
vous en parle en fin de vidéo quand on
parle de ma chaîne on dit de plus en
plus avant il faisait de la philo
maintenant c'est surtout ses réflexions
personnelles il y a un peu de philo mais
c'est de plus en plus du développement
personnel et un petit truc péjoratif là
dedans je crois alors moi je le prends
pas du tout comme tel mais je sais que
dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens c'est
le cas et donc du coup indirectement
parfois bas je me demande si je le
ressens pas comme tel est ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est que cet aspect
péjoratif liés au développement
personnel
on le retrouve pas dans plein d'autres
pays par exemple et pour ça c'est simple
il suffit d'aller sur la page wikipedia
par exemple du développement personnel
et rien qu'en termes d'un trop on peut
changer donc deux langues sur wikipédia
et on se rend compte que c'est pas du
tout la même manière de présenter les
choses
suivant chaque langue par exemple en
français on a le développement personnel
n'a pas de définition institutionnels et
cette formule peut être utilisée pour
légitimer des méthodes très variés parmi
ces diverses techniques et approches
certaines relèvent du charlatanisme qui
exploitent la misère émotionnel humaine
quand d'autres constituent des
pseudosciences et relève de
l'escroquerie ou de la manipulation
mentale voire de la dérive sectaire
ça fait mal alors en anglais rien de
tout ça juste à la toute fin de
l'article
on parle l'intro l'article il ya une
partie critique et en quatre lignes
ça reprend les thèses d'un auteur
américain mais rien dès l'intro
contrairement à l'article français et
c'est la même chose pour les articles
espagnol portugais néerlandais
à chaque fois il n'y a rien dans l'intro
à la sécu d'un trou équipe et dia je
suis d'accord avec vous mais pour moi ça
en dit long et surtout sa corroborent ce
que j'observe de moi même avec ma
famille qui aux états unis et le fait
que je vive en france moi je me rends
compte à quel point ces des mondes très
différents là dessus alors d'où vient
cette aversion qu'on peut avoir en
france là je pense que la réponse n'est
pas évidente et en fait elle se fait en
plusieurs parties d'abord notre
attachement à la philosophie dans
l'esprit des gens est une forme
d'incompatibilité entre la philo et le
développement personnel la philosophie
elle à la recherche de vérité elle est
rigoureuse elle argumente elle pense
elle se demande pourquoi là où le
développement personnel
il va être dans l'action dans le
pragmatisme dans l'imprécision il va se
demander comment sans savoir si c'est
forcément une bonne chose ou non à sa
faut aussi rajouter que le développement
personnel se fait beaucoup de thunes la
philo
coût - et en même temps voilà la philo
ça parle à une élite quoi la philo et se
veut un petit peu inaccessible et quand
ça devient trop accessible quelque part
c'est plus la philo et d'ailleurs je
trouve ça triste c'est pour ça que j'ai
essayé sur ma chaîne pendant des années
de la rendre accessible mais du coup en
le faisant
c'était de l'introduction à la
philosophie c'était pas vraiment de la
philosophie en tant que tel huey cyrus
du montage je sais pas pourquoi je parle
au passé parce que je trouve qu'en fait
je le fais encore je le fait
différemment mais je le fais encore je
trouve ouais évidemment il ya plein de
gens qui disent que oui c'est la
philosophie prem mais les gens qui
disent que non ce n'est pas le cas alors
que le développement personnel ça parle
à tout le monde
tout le monde comprend après on adhère
on n'adhère pas c'est une chose mais au
moins on comprend
est ce que je trouve intéressant aussi
c'est que les deux n'ont pas le même
rapport le même point de vue l'un envers
l'autre le développement personnel aime
beaucoup la philosophie est d'ailleurs
l'utilisent pour crédibiliser certains
de ses ouvrages de ses textes et c'est
là où la philosophie est et est le
développement personnel
la plupart du temps en tout cas c'est
mon impression et c'est un peu
corroborée par ce livre par exemple de
julia de funès donc docteur en
philosophie qui s'appelle développement
un personnel le succès d'une imposture
et c'est hardcore ça tire à balles
réelles 1 comme on dit dans le jargon
je vous lire un extrait par exemple sur
les coachs nombreux sont les coaches
désireux d'être psychologue
psychanalyste ou psychiatre mais les
concours de médecine où les examens de
psychologie de me réserver aux plus
travailleur d'entre nous riesch alors je
vais pas rentrer dans les attaques
contre le développement personnel que je
trouve injustifiée où ils sont faites
par des gens qui connaissent très mal le
milieu je trouve mais par contre c'est
vrai que il y a des aspects négatifs au
développement personnel et ça on peut
les identifier
déjà il peut y avoir une dépendance en
gros certaines personnes vont se sentir
bien en lisant un bouquin de
développement personnel parce qu'on se
sent booster on a la patate ça nous
permet douala ii de croire en plein de
choses on a envie de conquérir le monde
et donc on s'attache finalement à cette
sensation c'est hyper agréable cette
sensation on al'impression pouvoir
mettre en place tous les changements
qu'on veut dans notre vie le souci c'est
que certaines personnes voilà être tombe
dans ce truc où elles vont pas mettre en
place les méthodes vont pas faire les
efforts qu'il faut etc et vont juste
finalement continuer de lire des livres
de ce type et donc c'est un peu comme si
elle se développer personnellement mais
par procuration un peu donc ça se
porterait une sorte de dépendance on va
pas lire le livre de développement
personnel pour s'améliorer
mais entre guillemets juste par plaisir
et c'est pas super enrichissant de faire
ça je pense alors c'est pas très très
grave
quand c'est une dépendance qui est au
niveau du bouquin mais quand ça se passe
au niveau des coachs là c'est plus
embêtant parce qu'ils peuvent vous
prendre beaucoup plus qui nous apporte
évidemment ça dépend des coachs mais ça
ça peut être vraiment relou un autre
même que ça peut entraîner c'est que
parfois si on nous donne l'illusion que
tout est possible tout est réalisable
et donc quand on n'y arrive pas bah
c'est encore plus difficile et c'est
même parfois humiliant et donc on
voulait avoir plus d'estimé de soi on se
retrouve avec une estime de soi qui est
encore moins forte
donc c'est là c'est la déprime quoi donc
on est triste on n'est pas bien mauvaise
vibes et enfin il ya des gens que ça
fait culpabiliser et ça j'avoue j'ai
plus de mal à comprendre c'est un
commentaire qui est d'ailleurs ce matin
vidéo par exemple sur la productivité
avec l homme masqué tout j'ai vu des
commentaires genre ça ne fait
culpabiliser cette vidéo et ça me gêne
vachement j'ai vachement un problème
avec ça parce qu'en fait c'est faux une
des premières choses qu'on apprend en
communication non violente ou quand on
commence à travailler sur ses émotions
c'est que on est responsable de ses
émotions et on n'a pas à tenir les
autres responsables de ces émotions à
soi on peut être désolé que la personne
se sentent blessés et sud est quelque
chose qu'on a dit par exemple mais on
n'est pas responsable de ce que la
personne ressent ça c'est la base des
rapports bienveillant parce que si vous
faites porter à l'autre la
responsabilité de vos émotions
il peut pas y avoir de bienveillance pas
y avoir que des reproches que la non
remise en question c'est pas possible
quand je vivais sur la productivité et
que chanson un message or cette vidéo me
fait culpabiliser
c'est un abus de langage qui est hyper
néfaste parce qu'il entraîne cette
déresponsabilisation
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait je prends
la décision de regarder cette vidéo
ok décision libre ou s'il ya un titre
enfin bref tout est clair je prends la
décision de regarder ses vidéos je
ressent de la culpabilité
il ya des chances pour que cette
culpabilité et je la ressens tu parce
que quand je regarde cette vidéo
mon estime de moi diminue c'est très
différent de cette vidéo me culpabiliser
parce que ça laisse entendre que
l'auteur de la culpabilisation
c'est la vidéo alors qu'en fait c'est
soi
c'est le décalage entre ce qu'on
aimerait être par rapport à ce qu'on est
donc ça pour moi la question la
culpabilisation ça n'en est pas une
c'est triste que des gens culpabiliser
quand ils sont face à ce type de contenu
c'est sûr mais personne ne les oblige à
s'y confronter
y'a pas de soucis et si elle s'y
confrontent et qu' elle culpabilise pas
ya certaines personnes qui vont rester
en sécurité là il ya d'autres personnes
qui vont vouloir travailler cette
culpabilité et sa lettre le
déclenchement d'autres choses ont réagi
tous de manière différente pour les deux
soucis précédent c'est plus compliqué
mais ça fait penser au sport
on retrouve ces mêmes problématiques
dans le sport je trouve un les salles de
sport et les coachs qu on raque alors
qu'on n'y va pas 2 les gens qui partent
d'un des extrêmes qui deviennent
bodybuildé de ouf qui se shoote aux
stéroïdes
c'est même dangereux pour la santé 3 le
fait qu'on nous fasse rêver avec des
corps de rêve et cetera et puis voilà
entraînement facile et c est en fait bas
quand on n'y arrive pas on annonce que
ce qu'ils ne soient qui est encore plus
basses qu'à laon est ce que pour autant
on va avoir une image négative du sport
ou même une image négative de la
musculation et du fitness
non non pourquoi parce qu'on considère
que ça apporte plus de bien que de mal
et bien c'est un peu ce que je pense du
développement personnel
d'ailleurs c'est pas un peu ce que je
pense c'est exactement ce que je pense
ce qui nous manque c'est de revenir à la
base de ce qu'est le développement
personnel
c'est se développer personnellement ce
qui vient de se passer c'était vraiment
le climax de ma réflexion j'espère que
vous le retiendrait c'est très large
comme concept quoi et donc vu que ces
larges
forcément il avait choisi sont sensés et
des choses qui le sont beaucoup moins
et à mon sens la philosophie c'est aussi
du développement personnel au sens
strict de se développer personnellement
alors il ya des partis qui n'ont rien à
voir dans la philosophie avec le
développement personnel et encore je
pense qu'on pourrait faire des ponts
mais voilà typiquement la métaphysique
peu de choses à voir avec le
développement personnel
pareil pour l'épistémologie comment on
connaît ce qu'on connaît tous ce qui est
comme en acquièrent les connaissances
etc
la science du savoir quoi par contre
quand on ouvre la porte de l'action
logitech donc on tombe sur l'éthique et
donc l'éthique personnelle
là on s'en rapproche beaucoup plus pour
moi ça devient du développement
personnel puisque le but secret une
éthique personnelle et donc par exemple
le stoïcisme
épicurisme qui sont d éthique
personnelle éparses et du développement
personnel
quand senna qui nous écrit de la vie
heureuse et qu'ils expliquent selon lui
comment faire pour vivre une vie
heureuse si du développement personnel
et c'est la philosophie aussi bien sûr
mais ça reste également du développement
personnel
quand je lis et nec quand je dis
epictète quand je dis et pictures je
suis censé aller mieux trouver des
manières des choses que je peux mettre
en place dans ma vie pour mieux la gérer
excusez moi si j'ai tellement personnel
m arthur schopenhauer qu'en effet l'art
d'être heureux ou l'art d'avoir toujours
raison
excusez moi c'est pas des bouquins de
titres de bouquins de des lois au
personnel ça pourtant c'est schopenhauer
dont on parle est pas la même façon
aujourd'hui il ya des livres de
développement personnel qui sont
extrêmement intéressants
l'un des plus vendus c'est le pouvoir du
moment présent de écartelée c'est une
incroyable vulgarisation des grands
principes bouddhiste donc parce que tu
as 2 3 et charlatans qui font de la tude
excusez moi mon vocabulaire
excusez moi mon vocabulaire tu dois
jeter à la poubelle
le principe juste s'explorer de se
comprendre de travailler sur soi et de
s'améliorer
ça n'a aucun sens de faire ça et je vous
ça fait vraiment de la peine quand il ya
des gens qui ont cette image du
développement personnel parce que c'est
des gens qui passent à côté de choses
qui pourraient être intéressantes
juste à cause un préjugé et ça c'est
dommage et un passage que j'ai trouvé
amusant dans le livre de julia de funès
c'est au sujet de l'idéologie de
l'introspection et en parlant du
développement personnel et dit la chose
suivante
ces conseils tournent tous autour d'une
nécessaire introspection méditer seul
devant son application en position de
lotus pour mieux se retrouver se
concentrer sur sa manière de s'exprimer
pour mieux communiquer peser chaque
calorie et mesurer chaque effort pour
mieux se porter partir en retraite pour
se ressourcer et c'est l'alignement
personnel la connaissance de soi
l'épanouissement passerait
nécessairement par cette concentration
narcissique
ce rétrécissement vers le mois mais la
connaissance de soi est elle
nécessairement introspective autarcique
et narcissique alors tout notre
connaissance de soi non parce qu'on se
définit aussi dans nos rapports par
rapport aux autres par rapport à son
environnement et cetera mais une énorme
partie quand même se connaître soi ça
demande une introspection
non un petit peu quand même
et pour contrer ça m est des
constructions le mois ne serait-il
qu'une fiction mais c'est un concept
phare du développement personnel
on retrouve en plein de bouquins
développement personnel c'est de cette
idée du mois fiction donc j'ai quand
même l'impression qu'aujourd'hui tout la
version qu'on peut trouver contre le
développement personnel vient d'un
manque de connaissance de ce que c'est
le développement personnel
j'en ai marre de dire ce mot par contre
c'est pas juste un américain qui est là
on va
you can't wait du raf ii par world in
you c'est pas que ça c'est ça parfois
c'est vrai mais c'est pas que ça
donc finalement est-ce que le vrai
problème du développement personnel
c'est qu'on lui laisse pas sa chance de
vraiment se présenter
j'avoue que personnellement c'est
quelque chose que j'ai découvert assez
jeune après la philo quand même et
c'était vraiment un kiff à explorer et
narrant de choses intéressantes que j'ai
appris en fait je me suis dit hé mais
tout le temps que je mets à être
meilleurs à ce jeu vidéo à apprendre
telle langue à apprendre tel concept tel
machin etc
imagine je m'étais autant de temps juste
sur moi sur m'améliorer mois et être une
meilleure personne c'est un
développement personnel
bon après je me suis remis à jouer à
pokémon très vite mais de temps en temps
j'utilisais un bouquin et je pense que
ça m'a aidé même si évidemment rien ne
vaut les cols de la vie et les gifle au
visage que vous mais l'existence vous ai
parlé à ma rupture ou pas mais c'est un
plus après évidemment c'est pas quelque
chose qui va régler tous vos problèmes
il faut pas le voir comme ça et si vous
pensez que ça va résoudre des problèmes
intérieurs mais que ça vous apporte pas
ce que vous cherchez
faut pas hésiter à les voir des
professionnels genre des psys par
exemple je précise d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya
pas d'exclusion entre ces domaines là ça
que vous pouvez très bien lire du
développement personnel vous intéresser
à la philosophie être féru de
philosophie à garder des conférences de
hegel par exemple et avoir un psy c'est
possible quand je parle de conférences
de eagle s'est pas vraiment eagle qui
fait la conférence c'est une conférence
sur hegel à son époque est pas les
caméras et tout ce qu'il est mort ya
longtemps quand même après si vous
voulez découvrir des bouquins de
développement personnel sans perdre trop
de temps et comme ça vous savez lequel
vous voulez lire ou non etc
je vous recommande évidemment le sponsor
de cette vidéo
cooper cooper cenap qui vous permet de
retrouver des résumés de bouquins de
documentaires de podcasts alors
évidemment on parle de non fictionné 1
ça n'a pas de sens d'avoir un résumé de
harry potter et les thématiques c'est
culture générale développement personnel
donc c'est pour ça que c'est approprié
je trouve d'en parler dans cette vidéo
et développement professionnel
alors je vais totalement honnête et
transparent avec vous j'ai d'abord testé
un concurrent de couleur avant de les
connaître
donc c'était il ya longtemps et c'était
que en anglais donc pas mal roulé or là
tout en français en plus c'est une boîte
française
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux et ce
qui est cool aussi avec cooper c'est que
les résumés de bouquins ils sont six en
audio donc vous pouvez le faire pendant
que vous faites vos sports je faisais
vachement ça par exemple je parle au
passé parce que je le faisais pendant
que je pourrais je cours plus voilà
c'est pas du tout de ça donc j'ai envie
de vous parler je vais vous parler de
combat en temps normal ces 7 99 par mois
ou 6 67 par mois avec un abonnement à
l'année mais là avec le lien que je mens
description vous pouvez essayer cooper
premium gratos pendant un mois je les
remercie évidemment j'espère que vous
allez découvrir plein de trucs cool que
vous soyez pas les voir en temps normal
par exemple à un moment je me suis
vachement intéressé à l'éducation
bah voilà en temps normal je serai pas
les acheter des livres d'éducation ou
lire des livres entiers et s'élance
enfin j'ai pas d'enfant je parle alors
tout de suite peut-être j'en aurai
jamais j'en sais rien mais ce que j'ai
ce que c'était pas mon projet alors que
là avec un petit truc comme ça ou c'est
des résumés et touba j'ai pu
intéressé et j'ai pu satisfaire ma
curiosité quoi et juste pour ça c'est un
outil incroyable et du coup je pense que
ça vous parler parce que je sais à quel
point vous êtes curieux
n'oubliez pas le lien en descriptions
encore merci à cooper d'alors sponsorise
cette vidéo merci à julia de funès pour
avoir écrit ce bouquin qui m'a permis de
mieux comprendre pourquoi les
philosophes déteste le développement
personnel
merci à celles et ceux qui font du beau
développement personnel et à tous les
charlatans
j'espère que vous allez croupir six
pieds sous terre entre enfer rongé par
des verts finalement comme nous tous
memento mori you sir du montage alors en
fait pas comme nous tous parce qu'un
gars qui vont vouloir être incinéré par
exemple aux autres ils vont mourir en
mer et donc ça serions pas toucher la
terre parce que le temps qu'ils tombent
ils vont se faire bouffer par plein de
trucs je retire de nous tous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo
tous les mardis 22 heures sur twitter
suivez moi sur instagram love peace chao
et n'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo si
ce n'est pas déjà fait je vous en parle
jamais je vous le dis jamais mais je
vous dit peut-être que je devrais le
dire plus souvent donc voilà je le dis
goodbye